Wait why is it wait no we beat these
Angry Mark: We beat theeoo....
No we beat these. No they're all locked for me why are they locked
Bob: Why am I on a boat in the middle of the ocean?
Ok were movin'
Wade: Because we are on our way to... Bob: OK
Wade: Uh, where the hell's the next land at?
It's... Bob: HERE!
Bob: Oh ok cool ok
Wade: Christmas Time!
Alright
Bob: There's snow man
Wade: Ho Ho Ho, we are a Ho ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Wade: Welcome to the chill
Bob: Ahh, it's an ice axe
Wade: Alright, I don't remember...
*Sounds of shock*
Bob: Oh shit, the ice oh Jesus I understand now
*Sounds of emphasis on movements*
Bob: Oh fuck
I've forgotten how to play really
Bob: Hyeh
Bob: No, that's not a thing
OHHHHNOOOOO
WAIIITWAITWAIT lets talk about this aye I made it
Nice go
Go for it
You just gotta go onto that thing
Wade: To the left